so i'm going to take you to 21 may 2016.
what do you recall
with respect to
a telephone call you received from amber
sure
um i was in new york
um
i was there visiting family
um
i was in green point brooklyn
i was walking down matt avenue
and
i got i believe a text message from
amber that said something to the effect
of like can you talk and so i called
and i was walking down the street as
this happened
she put me on speakerphone so i was
talking to both of them he just stopped
by to pick up some of his stuff
and he has a theory that he
either he wants to ask you about her and
i said okay
sure
hello johnny like you know
and
he
i think it was he said or she said
[Music]
um
johnny thinks that
you and i together
defecated on his pillow
i think the words were used were
on his pillow
so i started laughing i was laughing she
was laughing
and when i realized that he was serious
i was like okay
look you know first of all
i wasn't there that day and so he got
very agitated by the fact that she and i
thought it was funny and he started to
get
um
more and more agitated and i could hear
him walk away
from the phone
he came clomping back down the stairs i
heard like a
noise and then the phone dropped
and um
he said to her
oh
you think i hit you
you think i
hit you
what if i peel your
hair back
and then i heard the phone drop again
and then i heard her scream
i remember her screaming
and i hung up the phone
and i called raquel immediately because
i know that she
lives
one door away and would her and her
boyfriend josh who's a big dude would be
able to get there the fastest
and
um i i called or texted her right away
and
i hung up with her and immediately
called 911 in new york
and then i called
a friend of mine
in la who i knew had met amber a number
of times and
i think
i may have placed a second call to nypd
now i'm all frazzled and i don't
remember
you